Sing the song of the Seven Sandpiper.
You’re nothing, you’re less. You’re broken, a mess. Defeated and hopeless, you’ll sink to the depths.
The oppressors are mighty, way greater in strength.
Let history warn you resistance means death.
Forget all they’ve told you, for history’s fine glow
is tarnished by those who don’t want you to know
the power of your stories, your songs, and yourselves
to take back the land for the dwarves and the elves.
So sing loud and proud, the Song of the Seven!
Be you halfling or gnome, be you dwarven or elven!
You carry their stories, no oppressor can hide them!
Carry their glories and rise! We will rise!
Sing loud and proud, the Song of the Seven!
Be you halfling or gnome, be you dwarven or elven!
You carry their stories, no oppressor can hide them!
Carry their glories and rise! We will rise!
Bonded in a blood quest, for vengeance and truth.
Destined to fail, but the Seven refused.
Seven warriors apart, unite as one fist.
The empire would crush them, but they said fuck this!
THEY SAID FUCK THIS!
They rallied the people, with brave deed and song.
Their courage has shown them the right from the wrong.
The power of a story, put fire in their veins.
The people will rise up to bring forth a change.
So sing loud and proud, the Song of the Seven!
Be you halfling or gnome, be you dwarven or elven!
You carry their stories, no oppressor can hide them!
Carry their glories and rise! We will rise!
Sing loud and proud, the Song of the Seven!
Be you halfling or gnome, be you dwarven or elven!
You carry their stories, no oppressor can hide them!
Carry their glories and rise! We will rise!
We will rise! Oh, we will rise!
Ohhhhhhhh!
Sing loud and proud, the Song of the Seven!
Be you halfling or gnome, be you dwarven or elven!
You carry their stories, no oppressor can hide them!
Carry their glories and rise! We will rise!
Sing loud and proud, the Song of the Seven!
Be you halfling or gnome, be you dwarven or elven!
You carry their stories, no oppressor can hide them!
Carry their glories and rise! We will rise!
Rise! We will rise!